greed fear and pride SRA effect uh and I
have done all three uh and all three
will make you broke see pride is I buy a
car to impress someone at a stoplight
that I will never meet would I buy this
if no one ever saw it oh yeah that's
your test on the pride button right
greed is I'm just Money Motivated to the
exclusion of other things that are
healthy you can have a money motivation
and not and not being excluded to the
exclusion of other things but if you're
only if your only button to push is
money that's great and the third one I
love you said is desperate that's the
worst one when you get desperate just
about 20 seconds later after I get
desperate I get stupid and right after I
get stupid I get broke right I mean it's
a progressive causal thing desperate
leads to stupid leads to broke